- Good morning believe nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe that you
have something special
that when you unleash it
it will be able to change the world.
So to help you on your
journey today's message is
work hard.
Over to you James Hedfield.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Most things in life that are worthwhile,
you got to work at it.
You got to work at.
You get out what you put in.
It's simple as that.
That's a kind of a universal law.
So yeah, it's not pick
up the guitar and go
ha, ha, which I've done, you know,
in front of the mirror lots, you know.
Hey, I'm really good and
you got to have that attitude too.
But it does take work, it does take
you know, some dedication, you know.
But if you love doing
it, it's not as hard as
it could be if you're doing something
that you're not as interested in.
- So on this channel we've
covered more successful
people maybe than any
other channel on YouTube.
I'd put it up against a lot of other
internet properties just in general.
We've covered entrepreneurs and athletes
and musicians and
innovators and politicians
and people who've had success
from all walks of life.
And one of the most consistent
themes that come up,
is you need to work hard.
Everybody works hard.
There's nobody who is really crushing it
who's spending ten hours a
week working on their thing.
And you have to love
what you're doing because
that's the only way you're
going to keep doing it.
The only way you're going
to deal with all of the crap
of learning your craft
and all the rejection
and all the failure and all
the things that don't work out
at the beginning.
The only thing that gets you through is
you actually love the process.
You love the work so it
doesn't feel like work.
It's one of the most
repeated piece of advice
that comes over and over
and over and over again
on this channel.
And so if you want to become
world class at something,
you want to be the Michael
Jordan of your industry,
then you have to put in the work to get
really really really really good.
And yes you're working smart,
but you have to work hard as well.
And so a quick story with
Alex from Toronto Dance Salsa
who I hired to help me run the business
and he's also an instructor here.
And recently we made a video where
we were talking about him wanting to be
the best instructor in Canada at salsa
and he was trying to
figure out his schedule.
And he wanted to go down
to one or two days a week.
And I told him that,
if you want to be the
best once or twice a week
is not enough.
In your world, you could get
deals just teaching Level 6
and just teaching Mondays.
- That's not enough you think?
- Not enough for you to get good.
I'll think you'll lose it.
- Really?
- Yeah.
If you wanted to just be a
manager and just be a coach,
then it's a different story.
But if you want to be the best instructor,
doing one night a week,
is not going to be enough.
- Yeah, I didn't think about that.
I don't want to be mediocre.
- And then if I bring
that to my own business,
if I want to have more success on YouTube,
I need to put in more reps.
Like, I'm doing three videos a day.
We've done over 5,000 videos
on this channel, right.
You better get better at something
if you're doing it 5,000 times
over and over and over
and over and over again.
When I started working with my agency,
I was considered the worst
and I became the best
in a couple of months.
Not because I had talent or skill,
it was because I was
doing three videos a day
when everybody else was having a hard time
trying to do one video a week.
Right?
You're just going to get better faster
because you're putting in the work.
And so whatever it is that
you want to get great at,
and obviously there's some restrictions,
maybe you have a full time job,
you know maybe you can't dedicate
100% of your time to it yet,
it's understandable but you need
to work everyday on your craft.
And you need to get better
and better and better
and better and better consistently
Michael Jordan became Michael Jordan
because of all the practice that he did.
Did he have natural talent?
Yes, but he worked and
he worked and he worked.
And if you just write people off,
you look at anybody who's
at the top of their field
and you say well they're there because
they're naturally gifted.
If that's the reasoning
for why they're successful,
and why you aren't more
successful, you're going to lose.
Don't disrespect the amount
of effort and hard work
that they are putting in.
Don't disrespect the amount of hard work
Michael Jordan put into
becoming Michael Jordan.
Because if you just chalk
it up to natural talent,
you're going to lose at whatever
it is that you're doing.
Hard work almost always
beats natural talent
in almost any field.
And that sucks because
it's a lot of hard work,
but it's also great in
that anybody can win.
Like if you badly want to
win at what you're doing,
as an entrepreneur, as
an actor, as a singer,
as a guitarist, whatever it is,
if you badly want to win, you can.
You just have to pay
the price of hard work.
So the question of the
day today is I'm curious,
are you working hard enough on the thing
that you say you want to be great at?
Are you really putting in
enough work to become the best?
I'd love to hear from you.
Leave your thoughts down
in the comments below.
I also want to give a
quick shoutout to Boaz.
Boaz thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, I appreciate the support.
And I hope you enjoy the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Being in a band you have to
constantly reinvent yourself.
You have to constantly be reminded
how there's someone better than you.
Every other weekend.
You're constantly reminded of how
you have nothing without your fans.
So you have to take into
account what they're thinking
and what they're interested in.
And all those things matter.
But it doesn't matter what art you do.
It doesn't matter if it's making an album
or a movie or a book or whatever.
You have to think, thinking
about all those types of things,
the hard work involved.
If you want to have like a casual life and
you don't want to be in a band.
I mean, you never sleep.
It's really really hard work.
And you're exhausted all the time.
And you're almost always sick.
And you're fighting with
your business partners
all day long.
And it's just how it is.
But I have a very very strong work ethic
because I had nothing when I was a kid.
Nothing.
I had my first job when I was 13.
I had two jobs when I was 16.
But I think a lot of it is probably
because I'm extraordinarily fearful
about having to do what
someone tells me to do.
So I'd rather be doing everything
because at least no one's
telling me to do that.
- You literally are, for
many of us in this room
and watching, movie wise,
you are the soundtrack of our lives.
So much of your stuff is
obviously well known to your point
and some stuff maybe not as well known,
but how do you know?
Is there something inside of you?
How do you know when you get it right?
Do you know when you get it right?
- Very very rarely.
You hope you've gotten 90% of it
or as close to it as you can.
But at least with me, and
I think with most writers
of any kind, you really
don't say eureka, this is it.
It's work on this, come back the next week
and reshape it and do it like
a sculp-- keep honing away at.
I'm not so brilliant that I
can sit down and write a melody
or a theme or a whole
scene or a whole work,
as Mozart might have done, we're told,
dashing it off like a letter
and the grammar's perfect.
Writing music it's very very hard work.
And for orchestra particularly,
so it's a labor intensive thing.
I have to be in the
room alone all the time
because that's the life that it is.
- It's hard work and it's lonely work.
- It's hard work, it's lonely work,
it's labor intensive, I
still use a pencil and paper.
I don't have a computer.
- You're old school.
- Old school, I've been
so busy fortunately
that I haven't been able
to go back and retool.
When I was studying music,
there were no computers.
We didn't have it.
- The secret to success,
there's a couple of elements
that are important in success.
First of all, it's your
own level of expectation.
You also have to learn to be happy
with what you achieve sometimes.
It's impossible in life to always achieve
exactly what you have in
the back of your head.
So you need to learn also to be
happy with what you achieved.
Even if it's only half of
what you had in mind at first.
I like a quote of John Lennon,
life's what's happening
to you when you're busy
making other plans.
And that is what I keep
telling my wife as well.
And a lot of people around me.
You always expect something and then
something along the way comes,
and then you have to
alter your path again.
And if you can learn to live with that,
if you can be practical like that,
then success is more easy, maybe.
It's good to have a plan.
But it's also good, if
you're working really hard
and you're walking up against a door,
and you can't go through that door,
then you just find a back door.
Just find your way around it.
And that's just the way that life is.
Sometimes you cannot get
exactly what you want
or what you had in the back of your mind.
Yes it's very important that you have
to have a good work ethic.
Nobody gets anywhere without hard work.
And you'll have good and bad days.
Even myself as a producer,
I run into disappointments
almost on a daily basis
because I try to work with artists that
on the last moment pull back their song or
you know you don't see that.
You don't read that in the news.
But it's the fact of the matter.
And I think all artists have
to deal with stuff like that.
You don't get the set times you want.
You don't get the billing you want.
You don't get the hotel
room that you requested.
It's something you have to deal with
and it defines your
character how easy you are
to deal with stuff like that.
You know life is a rollercoaster
ride for everybody.
It has its ups and its downs.
But if everything goes well,
you'll have more ups than downs.
And you'll remember the ups more than
you'll remember the downs.
But it's a fact of the matter,
everybody no matter if
you're a big artist,
a successful artist or a
successful businessman,
everybody works hard to get somewhere.